now here on the angle we actually
believe in spending cuts the government
has grown fat and way too happy with
woke
and that includes the Pentagon if they
keep focusing on things that are
actually going to harm our Readiness
instead of focusing on what we need a
military ready to take on our enemies
well thankfully some in Congress agree
with that and during a markup of the
National Defense authorization act
Republicans including my next guest
proposed changes that targeted diversity
equity and inclusion programs
to my colleagues questions about whether
or not I intend to use this hearing to
go after the diversity equity and
inclusion initiatives and the critical
race theory in the military the answer
to that question is unequivocally yes I
view this not as a wedge issue not as
divisive but as remedial we have to go
and remediate the bad things that have
happened as a consequence of this
Embrace of radical gender ideology and
radical race ideology
now one of the Amendments Gates proposed
was to get rid of the pentagon's chief
diversity officer well it passed but he
wanted to go a step further and
eliminate Federal funding for all DEH
Dei training that Amendment he says
failed after two Republicans joined
Democrats to defeat it kind of name
names joining me now Florida Congressman
Matt Gates of the house armed services
committee Congressman we reached out to
those two Republicans we're going to
name them Congressman bacon and Turner
Congressman Bacon's office responded in
part the amendment would have totally
cut all diversity training for the
military which is unreasonable all
service members should know that racism
and sexual harassment are not tolerated
in our military oh that's a weak
response your response to that as I
explained to Congressman bacon in the
committee we always have standards in
the military that don't allow people to
be racist or harmful to their fellow
service members and none of those
standards would have changed the
question is whether or not we ought to
have these Chief diversity officers and
Laura they're making as much as 183
thousand dollars per year compare that
to a private in the army or an Airman or
a sergeant working for our military tell
you what if the chief diversity officer
is what we need to win Wars maybe we
should send them all to the front lines
in Ukraine like now get them to Taiwan
but of course that's not the case this
dilutes our Readiness I'm glad that the
structural office has been eliminated
but you always have to follow the money
and that's why I'm going to continue to
pursue efforts to get all of the funding
removed yeah getting getting results I
mean people people talk about these
issues and freedom and all these
wonderful ideas generic Concepts that
are are important but what are the
results that Republicans bringing home
and I think you're trying to actually
show people we've done this we've cut
this this is bad for Readiness it's bad
for recruitment but the Republicans have
got to get on board here we on on these
woke programs we've gone through a lot
of them on the angle the the the the the
the huge celebration they had this month
at the Pentagon everything but military
Readiness was discussed yeah I mean
while China is focused on AI we're
focused on lgbtqai plus and it is
important for Republicans to understand
the damage this is doing because every
major institution the Democrats have
taken over from the Department of
Education to Justice to pop culture
they've destroyed it and we cannot allow
that to happen to our military our
service members are patriotic they are
not extremist they are not racist and
the problem really lies with some of the
senior leadership the woke some of these
people are horrible God bless their
service but they are just their their
views on this stuff is going to just
drive a lot of more traditional
Americans out of the military now here's
what one of your colleagues said at the
hearing today on the Democrat side of
the aisle was yesterday typical race
theory has been weaponized as a
political tool running away from history
does not help us have a stronger
military if we want a stronger military
we cannot run from CRT and we must
Embrace Dei is a central part of how we
lead
well she's right critical race theory
has been weaponized politically but it's
been weaponized by the left to get
people to believe that as a consequence
of their immutable traits they are
naturally oppressed or an oppressor and
people in the military minorities in the
military have come to me to talk about
how divisive this is that the whole
reason there's commonality in training
is the sense that you are one unit one
team and that we went from be all you
can be one of the greatest slogans of
all time to this Embrace of radical
gender ideology and radical race
ideology and you're right we should not
pass another authorizing act for this
military that does not uproot all of the
wokeness we know where to find it but it
takes political courage Laura because
you've got Corporate America and pastry
all pushing for an Embrace of this round
what are Republicans in in the majority
in Congress for in the house if they're
not going to do stuff like excise that
ridiculous spending what are they there
for this was the core Covenant that we
had with our voters to get in the
majority and it seems as though far too
many are willing to violate it
Congressman Gates thank you and we'll
stay updated on that hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else